I am Gallic response to backlash over an
op-ed she penned for the New York Times
titled being a feminist in Harvey
Weinstein's world in the piece published
on Friday the Big Bang Theory actress
wrote quote those of us in Hollywood who
don't represent an impossible standard
of beauty have the luxury of being
overlooked and in many cases ignored by
men of power unless we can make them
money she added that she makes choices
about her clothing and behavior that
make herself less prone to harassment
the piece attracted criticism with
readers accusing violet of implying that
women may be to blame for being harassed
because of the way they dress taking to
Twitter on Sunday Bialik wrote that her
words were taken out of context and were
twisted to quote imply that god forbid I
would blame a woman for her assault
based on her clothing or behavior she
added it's so sad how vicious people are
being when I basically live to make
things better for women Bialik also
announced that she will be doing a
facebook live session with the New York
Times on Monday to further discuss the
matter
[Music]